junko have you worked with anyone who
lead from an emotional or unbalanced
place but learn to detach and what
helped them well when I was putting
these questions together obviously
here's one where you also have to use a
little disarmed movement to get someone
that's getting emotional about something
you got to get them to calm down yeah so
you don't reciprocate the emotion don't
coach people when they're angry or
emotional that's not the time to say hey
you know what you need to do right now
is you need to calm down you know that
that doesn't work actually
Lafe was telling that story on the last
podcast where he was losing his temper
about something and I just you know
stood there and said kind of smiled and
said I didn't I didn't reciprocate the
anger I said hey take it easy
you know don't worry about it let's just
think about it can you make this happen
and he's like yeah I can of course I
actually I had a one of my one of my
senior enlisted advisors actually my
first deployment to Iraq and and he and
I were old school team one guy said what
one of my one of my favorite guys in the
world actually but he would sometimes
get a little bit emotional
a little bit a little bit he had this
tactic that I picked up from him that I
that I understood the way he the way he
addressed conflict was and I broke it
down for him eventually was simplify
amplify and repeat that's what he would
do and it actually worked and worked a
lot of time on most people and so like
first if I said hey I'm gonna need yep I
want to take a couple more guys on this
operation and if he didn't think I
needed more guys for an operation he'd
say well why don't you just take
everyone in the compound I'll tell you
what just take every person on the
roster we'll get people back you that'll
give you enough people then we'll take
everyone out I'll start rounding
everyone up right now we'll take every
single person that we have out there and
I'll even grab some army guys on the way
that was his way and
and I'd be like no we haven't no but
what I wouldn't do is I wouldn't get
defensive I would get fired of it and I
would say hey no I'm not saying I need
everybody I'm just saying I want to take
a three more guys there's some spaces
and the vehicles it'll give us a little
more ability to contain the target in
we'd look at that said look take a look
at the map we can and so then he keep
calm down baby and in this guy's case he
actually wasn't like too emotional he
was just super passionate and when I
actually broke down the simplify amplify
and intensify oh no simplify amplify and
repeat that's what you do simplify
amplify and repeat when and then when
whatever we would start in a discussion
and he would start doing it we would
start laughing because he realized it as
exactly so the simplify my repeat that's
that's what the name you put on his
little that wasn't his methodology yeah
you know if you said like I said if I
said I had need a couple more guys you
do we'll just take everyone then if
that's what you need right every single
guy to you he would simplify what you
said he would amplify it and make it
more extreme and he would just repeat it
or forgive and in most people that he
did it to they would feel stupid because
of what he did to him you know he'd say
well no I don't need no I just feel
stupid and he'd say so just that's
ridiculous and he'd win but we had we we
would laugh about it but but like I said
he wasn't actually too emotional he was
just fired up about stuff which is a
positive thing but someone that is
actually too emotional so like I said
you got to stay calm you don't don't
coach people when they're angry you set
a good example and then when people calm
down later you talk to him about like
amen
that wasn't cool and you kind of gotta
spin it right cuz you're trying to get
you turning you don't want to like
literally coach because if I say echo I
need to coach or something then you're
defensive and all that but if I say hey
man I I rely on you cuz of your
expertise and I think you're the only
guy
the platoon that can actually make this
happen so if you're losing your temper
man that doesn't all of a sudden I can't
count on you and I need you mm-hmm
because you don't make good none of us
make good decisions if we're all bent
out of shape on something mm-hmm so I
got a please can you just can you help
me by just hey man if you start if you
start getting angry about something just
realize it's gonna affect your
decision-making and we can't have that
man we need to come we need to make the
good assistance people are counting on
us
mm-hmm and that's how I'm handling
someone that gets emotional about stuff
yeah that that's what some simplify
repeat one but if i amplify i'm not say
all girls do this but some wives might
do like you said Charles you know
ultimately I think if you know and
you're if you're in a good relay you
don't really take it that seriously but
but yeah you say like I don't know you
know hey you you were you said something
mean to me or whatever and no but then
why do married me then why don't why
don't you just die amplify and repeat oh
yeah or worked out for that or hate go
to this one time long time she's uh she
said she want me to get orange juice I
went to the stores Quinn story wanted me
to get orange juice for whatever reason
I forgot the orange juice I need choose
not to get those she forgot just forgot
you know you come home forget the orange
juice she said something along the lines
of does anything I say have any
importance to you at all that's that's
what that is right yeah all she needs to
do is say it more than once and you got
to repeat as well that question no yeah
most things are pretty important I mean
maybe not the orange juice at that
moment you know I forgot another tactic
like when you talk to people like to
calm them down or whatever like let's
say something they lose their temper all
the time or something like that
and you have to address like them losing
their temper be like hey you know how I
use the word passionate passionate is
business basically like an excuse word
for someone being like you know what
people just mash it compassionate you
know
well you can't be it can't be a
euphemism well here's the thing being
passionate and being emotional are two
different things because you can be
passionate about something and not lose
your temper and not being in whether
they're two different things so people
will be like they'll put that on and so
it sounds kind of acceptable isn't
simply not true but so if but you can
use that to your advantage you can be
like hey I know you're passionate I dig
it man it's one of the things I like
about you and another thing that I like
about you is that you're also a thinker
that's why boom then you say what to do
keyline there is that's what I like
about you or what I like about you is
this and then they kind of take on that
role for sure you know you're disarming
yeah yeah very good very good